[Music]
all right guys here we go 6900 xt from
amd
kind of like the last graphics card
we've kind of been waiting on for this
entire launch season at least for the
end of this year
we're going to talk today about whether
or not it even holds a candle
to the rtx 3090 which is what it's kind
of been touted as being
the 30-90 killer by some other people
out there
and we're gonna see whether or not that
holds true today so hang on to your
butts this is going to be one of those
wild rides
um this is the top dog offering from amd
it's it's
re-entry into the extreme it's a bent
fin it's really bugging me oh oh sorry
distracted easily this is uh their
re-entry into the high-end
graphics market something we haven't
seen them attempt since back when vega
and radeon 7
was kind of sort of a thing but never
really competitive
this was touted to be a an rtx
3090-esque
card and i can tell you right now that
for the most part
it looks exactly like a 6800 xt the
cooler is identical the dimensions are
identical but it's a 999
msrp and obviously uh we're gonna talk
about pricing
in the hypothetical the msrp is exactly
what you could go and buy it for the
volatile
pricing and scalping and all that stuff
going on we're going to hope all the
pricing comes back to normal but we have
to go by the pricing that is actually
announced by the manufacturer that's the
way that
it works so whether or not you get it
for that price is obviously going to be
different
there are custom board partner cards
that will be coming out obviously
all your favorite brands like sapphire
and xfx and power color
and all of them that are the usual
suspects when it comes to making custom
amd cards
we'll be making custom 6900 xt's also
but
if the 6800 and 600 xt launch taught us
anything is that it seems like there was
even less allocation of amd cards
available for launch
than there was for nvidia so finding the
the amd cards is proving to be much
tougher than even nvidia so we're gonna
hope that
things do normalize but i've even
mentioned all this yes to get the
obvious out of the way that this is a
really crappy time for graphics card
launches for anyone trying to keep up
with demand
and getting it for the prices that
they're advertised for or at least msrp
is very very difficult so we're
obviously operating on the hypothetical
that you could walk into your big box
retailer or go to your favorite retailer
site and buy one for the price that
they're supposed to be
moving forward it's essentially a 6800
xt with obviously more processors or
more stream processors
and a higher power limit 300 watt is
what's advertised
but i'm going to go ahead and kind of go
right into the whole too long didn't
watch
spoiler alert this card was actually
fairly disappointing to me
this time around for several reasons to
understand those reasons go and show you
the charts
so that you guys can see how it compared
to the titles that we use
one thing i want you to notice here is i
completely omitted valhalla
assassin's creed bahala which is a new
title that we started using because of
extreme inconsistencies not only with
our amd cards
but our nvidia cards as well there's
something just obviously wrong and
broken with that card
and is it is an ubisoft title so that's
to be expected
but anyway let's go look at the charts
and let's talk about it
[Music]
so this is advertised as a 300 watt part
uh and
what amd was kind of doing is they were
kind of touting that they've got as much
power as a 3090 or up to a 390 with
rage mode and the smart access memory
turned on
which as you guys guys may notice with
our charts we are using an intel cpu
and not any sort of smart access memory
turned on because
one of the reasons why we don't use that
is one rage mode is something you have
to activate
and we test our cards out of the box
which means they come out of the box
they go onto the system they play games
that's how we do it that's how
most people operate their graphics cards
especially this time around with more
people buying graphics cards and
new systems for the first time they may
not be very versed in going in there and
tweaking these settings to get more
performance out of their card like rage
mode or
enabling smart access memory because of
the fact that um
there's so many people out here that are
that are doing this for the first time
and that's why i recently put out a
video showing of the basics of
understanding your graphics card so that
people could actually have a little bit
of of baseline knowledge on
what some of these specs mean what some
of the settings mean and what they're
seeing on screen and what that means
when they start looking at the
stuff in programs like gpuz and msi
afterburner and such
first things first you might have
noticed those charts were
quite the fps roller coaster just
complete swings from one end of the
spectrum to the other
just completely bottlenecked by the way
1080p we just took it off the chart
entirely because it is just bottleneck
city
obviously for both the 3090 and this
card it is just bottleneck city
um i can tell you right now it was some
1080p numbers were
lower than 1440p because the bottleneck
was so hard
uh and because the gpu was spending
probably more time swinging
its uh core clock speed because of how
hard it was being cpu bound
that we actually got less performance in
1080p than 1440 in many instances
so this card obviously being a 144hz
1440p card or a 60 plus fps 4k
card obviously is where this this thing
is sort of belongs um
those swings were just like it caused me
to investigate and go what
is going on here now it's important to
note the drivers that we test with
these are pre-release drivers they are
not the same driver
number that you'll see when you go and
update your radeon software to get the
latest drivers for your newest graphics
cards these are
i don't want to say band-aid drivers but
they really feel like it in many of
these instances where
they work but man we never know if we're
giving you the full
customer experience because they'll come
out with another driver on launch day
that is supposed to be a more official
like polished driver
so because of these massive fps swings
and some titles
we didn't even put it on the chart
because we're only comparing this to the
6800 xt the 3080 and the 3090
this card was being beaten by the 3070
in some titles
and that's because of not only driver
optimizations and titles that are
obviously a little bit more leaning
towards nvidia and the nvidia
technologies and then
the amd titles it's obvious that this
card wins with amd titles that have amd
logos on them because
you know subroutines and all that sort
of stuff maybe one day we'll do a video
about when people talk about intentional
bottlenecking
with one brand versus another that's all
about subroutine and the way it
does its instructions based on the card
that's identified something we can talk
about later but then i decided to
investigate
what is going on phil and i were like
did something happen with our cpu and
our memory did that get reset because we
do run an overclock on our 10900k to try
and alleviate as much of the bottlenecks
as possible that all checked out
nothing was wrong we had the right
driver installed
but then when we went into radeon
software by default
out of the box it's set to the profile
that's supposed to be
which is profile default
that just means out of the box settings
but we noticed under load
it was only limiting or was only
allowing 250 watt power draw
and i looked at phil i went 250 watts
okay interesting so what happens if i
increase the power consumption
or increase the power limit if you're
wondering what i'm talking about you
should go and watch our
video a few videos ago we explained what
all these settings mean so this card has
a boost limit of
22.50 out of the box now it was sitting
in the 2300s in as high as
the low 2400s just like the 6800 xt
it's obvious that amd's got a very high
clocking core in here however its ipc is
obviously lower than that of nvidia's
because of the fact that
if it was on par with it the higher
clock speeds would get you more
performance than we're actually seeing
out of this
so high clock speed is good but we just
need to get more you know oomph out of
each cycle
but we noticed 250 watt was where it was
stopping so i went ahead and maxed the
power limit which is
an additional 15 percent just like we
saw the 6800 xt
and the power limit immediately started
showing 300 watts
which allowed our core clock to come up
to nearly 2500 megahertz
and lock there well as we find out this
is a 300 watt card
and out of the box it was power limiting
to 250
which as such was also limiting the core
clocks but that doesn't necessarily hold
up either because if it's a 200 or 250
megahertz card
we were above that anyway in the high
2300s low 2400s
which tells us that the boost algorithm
based into the card or the turbo clocks
was happening so i can't really explain
the weirdness that we were seeing
the core clocks were higher than they
should have been for the standard boost
tables
however the power limit was 50 watts
below where it should have been and an
extra 50 watts
can level out the core clocks which
would keep some of these crazy swings
that we were seeing happen
now one other thing that we observed is
that we were getting uh
pretty close to and in some titles
exceeding 100 c on the junction
temperature which is the hottest part of
the die
and then over 80 c on the edge
temperature that's significantly warmer
than we were seeing on the 6800 xt
yeah but jay there's more cores in there
so that makes sense but that was at the
250 watt
as soon as i increase the power limit to
where it should be the 300 watt as it
should have been
out of the box then we saw the
temperature start to climb even higher
as high as 110
c again people would say that's normal
so there's kind of a
trifecta happening here one the card is
not being allowed 300 watts like it's
supposed to
at least not with this driver out of the
box with whatever bios is preloaded
on this card second the temperature was
high enough
to where that starts affecting your core
clocks as well to try and keep that
junction temperature from exceeding its
tj max
it's going to start to pull down core
clocks so now you have power limit
and temperature pulling down core clocks
the third thing here is the fan
algorithm on here is extremely
extremely conservative in that we could
never hear the fans on this
but if you allowed the fans to ramp up a
little more you might get the control
of or the temperature under control a
little better and then we would see a
little bit more stable core clock as
well
i have absolutely no doubt that a lot of
the performance fluctuations we were
seeing in performance
were directly related to those three
things which
it's kind of funny that i did the video
i recently did about how all those play
into the performance of a graphics card
because it's what allowed me to kind of
identify what was happening
with this card so with some titles also
just being completely poorly optimized
with drivers
uh ghost recons wildlands being one of
them yes i know that's like a
four-year-old title
maybe even more however we saw this card
performing
less perform or getting less fps than
our 30 70.
we're talking a 499 graphics card
versus a 999 graphics card
and let's say you had a 2080 ti which is
the 30 70 is equivalent to
and you were like i'm going to upgrade
to a 6900 xt
and that's one of your favorite titles
that you still play you took a downgrade
in performance by going to this card so
these are some of the things that you
hear people say with amd like
well they make great hardware but their
drivers suck and this is one of those
times that's a perfect example of that
and that we first observed that weird
performance you can go back and check
out our 6800 and 6800 xt review
where i showed the same thing with
wildlands
weeks and weeks ago giving us this
really weird low performance and low
not low utilization utilization showed
utilized for this card but the fps was
extremely low
well i had hoped to see that maybe the
driver would be updated and that this
this new architecture would be supported
in that title
a little better than it is at least some
sort of improvement since then
absolutely nothing
so that means the driver team and the
development team
it's an old title that at this point you
could probably consider forgotten when
it comes to the new hardware
so that would really stink if you're
seeing good numbers on new hardware like
borderlands 3 this card decimates all
and so does the 6800xt
that's an amd title nvidia does okay in
it
but because it's an amd title it
utilizes this card to its fullest
potential
and we see it literally mop the floor
with nvidia but we're not seeing that
across the board and we're not seeing
that nearly as closely as amd
like is kind of portraying in their
benchmarks and the reason for that
is all their benchmarks for this card
that we saw included
smart access memory turned on in rage
mode now first of all rage mode
it's almost complete bs because the card
is already boosting past its turbo clock
that it's advertised anyway so you're
getting a self-overclock out of this
smart access memory is something i don't
support right now and the reason for
that is it's one of the greedy sides of
amd kind of showing its ugly face
in that they could have supported
previous generation ryzen cards
no problem whatsoever or ryzen cpus
without having to limit it to 5000
series
now if you've tried to buy a 5000 series
cpu you know already they're as
much of a unicorn as these gpus are well
maybe not quite as much but close
in fact i've seen so many people
settling on buying 3000 series because
they simply cannot find a 5000 series
i'm not going to go as far as to call it
paper launch but i'm going to say it was
definitely
low inventory and low stock at launch
and it hasn't really been
readily restocked so the fact that amd
decided to limit something that they
could have allowed access to
to older cpus that are on the exact same
motherboard
as you need for smart access memory
which is a 500 series motherboard
there's absolutely no reason other than
greed that they should have locked it
down to the 5000 series
now that means for the majority of you
out there i'd say
in the high 90s percentile aren't going
to be able to use smart access memory
anyway because you don't have a 5000
series
so what we showed you is the real out of
the box performance experience you'll
get
with this card in its current state of
drivers
and just the way that various games are
utilizing this hardware
the 6800 and 6800 xt didn't seem to be
nearly as
limited as this card because like i just
said our particular model
with the drivers and whatever bios is
loaded on here
is limiting itself to 250 watt which is
50 watts
less or a significant amount of power
that the gpu needs to maintain its core
clocks
lower than it should have been out of
the box now i plan on investigating
seeing if a new bios or drivers will fix
this and doing another video about what
happens with the 300 watt
but if i bring you a review and say i
had to go in there and tweak it to get
the advertised numbers
then that's a that's a misrepresentative
review
so the review of this card is that as
shipped i can't recommend it
my recommendation if you're looking at
buying a graphics card that's an amazing
value again
based on msrp that would still be the
6800 non-xt
because you're getting numbers that are
really close to a 3080
at significantly less cost and faster
than a 30-70
again hypothetically if you can get your
hands on it phil and i were talking
about it and we feel like this card is
really more like
a 6900 non-xt and even then that's if it
works
flawlessly in all titles which we're not
experiencing
so like anything else i don't know if
it's rushed the hardware is not the
hardware's solid
the hardware's solid but it's only going
to be as good as the software supporting
it and i
really really want to hope that this is
not another ugly amd driver
issue again like we saw with the 5700 xt
i really hope amd gets their software
crap together
before these become widely available
because right now as far as the 6900xt
is concerned
i have to tell you just like the 3900
even at 500
less it's a horrible horrible value it
is closer to the performance of a 3080
than it is to the performance of a 30
90.
yes the price is also closer but not as
close as the performance is
so yes the 3090 being a terrible value
for gamers absolutely
a thousand dollar amd card that performs
like a 3080
is equally as bad and that's where i'm
gonna kind of leave this review
if you guys uh do me a favor watch more
reviews because
with a card like this that like i showed
you with some titles just completely
feels like it gets left out and no
optimizations at all
if you want to make sure that the card
is compatible with your favorite games
you need to find people that are
reviewing with your favorite games
because it's impossible
for a single reviewer to review every
game out there to show you what the
performance is going to be like
you've got to watch multiple reviews we
all use different test beds
different test methodologies and it's
your job as reviewers to
kind of absorb that information and
digest it and then poop out an opinion
on whether or not
you want one because you're going to
find different opinions different test
methodologies different fanboyisms and
different biases let's face it we all
have our biases
and you guys are already saying yeah jay
your bias is towards nvidia well
that's honestly because the software
side of it is so solid
and it really feels like this card like
the word that keeps coming to mind to me
is rushed
not the card the driver support for it
so like i said that's we're gonna leave
it watch as many reviews as you can
because face it that's all you can do
you can't really go out and buy it i
guarantee
this is also gonna be a paper launch i
can call it a paper launch because if
everyone justified calling an nvidia
launch a paper launch the paper that
this has launched on hasn't launched yet
[Music]